oday, we're welcoming back an old friend of
the show, Ben Dixon, host of The Benjamin
Dixon Show.
Ben, always great to have you.
David, as always, a pleasure.
Glad to be back.
So, OK, I mean, how is Joe Biden doing so
far?
You know, that's a big question.
I feel like it's a loaded question.
But, you know, if you if you actually are
dealing fairly with Joe Biden, he's had some
good and he's had some bad.
Yeah, I am.
There are a lot of people who are really grateful
to have the the stimulus checks.
And while it wasn't as much as we wanted it
to be and while it wasn't, it didn't include
fifteen an hour, it still helped a lot of
people.
And there are some good things in it.
Right.
There's the fact that they have on poverty.
This bill is supposed to cut childhood poverty
by forty two to forty five percent.
We'll see how that does.
So I have to give them thumbs up on that,
even though it's not everything I think is
really beneficial.
So one of the big things that was missing
from the stimulus bill was the 15 dollar minimum
wage.
My view on this is that the problem is that
the Senate Democrat, the group of Senate Democrats,
just isn't left enough.
It's not that Comilla didn't push the Parlo
override the parliamentarian because we saw
with the vote that Democrats just didn't have
the votes for 15 dollar minimum wage.
So for me, it's less about, oh, Joe and Comilla
backed off by not overriding.
It's there aren't enough Democrats in the
Senate who want a 15 dollar minimum wage.
Do you see it that way or do you think they
should have pushed the overridden the parliamentarian?
Yeah, no, I definitely think they should have
overridden the parliamentarian if for no other
reason than to give us the fight that that
we wanted and that we needed on that issue.
However, you're not wrong, because then it
would have been Kyrsten Sinema, Joe Manchin
and the other six who sabotages before.
And so but that does speak to a bigger, broader
problem, like we are going to have to send
more progressive leaning senators there to
get things done.
And they absolutely are going to need to overturn
or abolish a filibuster or at least amended
if they want to get anything done going forward.
Yeah, I want to talk about filibuster, but
just to play out the overriding in practice,
we got the vote on including the minimum wage
anyway.
So we have a record of who voted no.
Wouldn't the override just have created the
fight, but in the end just delayed getting
people to cash?
What?
You know, it depends on the timing of it.
Like it could have delayed it a little bit
further.
But also it would have it really would have
shown.
And again, you make a great point.
We know the eight people who opposed it, but
then also would have been it would have been
a little bit more pressure because at that
point it had come down to a it came down to
the fifty vote versus what they needed in
terms of the 60.
So it gives them an opportunity to it really
gave the Democrats an out in the long run.
And it leaves the suspicion that perhaps they
didn't want to do it anyway.
Right.
But that's in the weeds.
And again, there are a lot of people who are
just grateful to have these checks because,
I mean, we're we're so far into this pandemic
and sixteen hundred versus two thousand fifteen
dollars an hour.
A lot of people want it.
We can come back to it.
But absolutely.
I mean, we I'm glad they got it done.
Yeah.
If it had not happened probably within five
to seven days of when it did, it probably
goes on a list of failures for Joe Biden.
No, absolutely.
Because, you know, the clock was ticking the
same, you know, my side of the equation.
We were putting pressure on him from everywhere.
Right.
We want a fifteen an hour.
And we one of those checks back in January.
Yeah.
You know, so, you know, they they did what
they could do.
And there's still enough good things in that
bill that I think are going to have structural
impacts, especially on childhood poverty.
I can't overestimate that or overstate that
because that's a really significant move.
And they are making they're giving us signals
that they want that to continue even after
this bill has run its course.
So filibuster, there's the option of eliminating
the filibuster with the pros and cons that
come with that, including what happens the
next time that Republicans are in control.
There's the idea of reform of the filibuster,
like, for example, requiring it to be an actual
talking filibuster rather than popping in
and extending debate and then and then leaving.
There's the idea of you need 40 in the chamber
to do it rather than the absence of 60 keeps
it going.
Where are you kind of coming down on this
debate right now?
You know, I.
For all intents and purposes, the willingness
to even from Joe Manchin, the willingness
to at least amend the filibuster so that it
is at a minimum a talking filibuster is a
positive signal.
However, there are just so many impediments
to to the actual progress that needs to happen
immediately, especially coming from Georgia,
like we absolutely are going to have to pass
some type of voting rights legislation.
It's got I know we already have H.R. one in
the House.
It's got to pass the Senate and the Republican
Party absolutely will use a talking filibuster
and they will tough it out in order to kill
that bill.
So I think while it is encouraging that they
want to amend it at a minimum, I don't know
that a standing filibuster is going to be
enough to actually beat back the the desires
of Republicans to suppress the vote across
the country.
I tend to agree with you and actually in thinking
about a lot of the possible big initiatives
that Joe Biden is considering.
So last week we heard maybe the next big thing
will be the tax reform plan.
This week we heard it might be a three trillion
dollar infrastructure plus schools and families.
Now there's a lot more discussion about gun
control in light of of the two shootings on
most of these things, I'm expecting Republican
support to not be close to zero, to be literally
zero.
Given that, how should how should Joe Biden
and Democrats even account for that in thinking
of what to approach next?
No, I think they honestly are going to have
to play hardball and, of course, see the fear
of the Republicans.
Mitch McConnell did that a couple of videos
twice making threats about what they would
do if the filibuster is abolished.
I think the response to that from Democrats
should be abolish a filibuster and run campaign
ads every single day, letting Americans know
exactly what Republicans want to do, what
they ever get back in power.
So I think they're going to have to play some
serious hardball and leverage the actual majority
in this country to ensure that they don't
get back in power in the near future.
One of the things I've been thinking about
is trying to get out of like our politics
bubble where we follow this stuff in a way
that most people don't.
And thinking like, for example, the debate
around whether covid cash passes with 60 or
with 50.
Right.
No one who was waiting on the fourteen hundred
cares that it passed with 50 instead of 60.
Right.
And along the same lines, when you think about
something like gun control, we know gun control
is less of a voting issue for people on the
left than it is for people on the right, the
right weaponize.
Is it whether or not Joe Biden is doing anything
they're saying Biden's coming for your guns.
Either way, taxation as an example, the narrative
of Biden's raising your taxes, even if they're
not really going up for 98 percent of households
or whatever the case may be.
Do you think that Joe Biden should be thinking
about which of his ideas are voting issues
versus which are not?
Or should he just be doing what he thinks
he can get done?
Actually, that's a really, really great question
and thank you, it is fourteen hundred versus
six hundred.
I honestly think that he needs to just simply
strike at what is going to be the best interests
of the people, because this is a really good
time where what he does that's in the best
interests for the majority of the American
people is actually really good politics.
Even if you do have the Republicans on the
other side of the aisle who are going to weaponize
literally anything, they're going to call
him a socialist.
When he's far from that, they're going to
say he's coming to take their guns when he's
not going to take their guns.
We're talking about like a universal background
check, which, you know, we're talking about
issues that have like 90 percent approval
rating in some categories.
So, you know, he needs to play hardball with
them and make his appeal to the American people
in a very direct way.
They need to communicate it.
They need to go across the country and make
sure I know we're in a pandemic, but they
need to make sure they take credit for all
the good things that they're going to do,
because if they don't, Republicans will vote
against it and then try to take credit for
it.
So on immigration, immigration to me feels
like if you watch the press briefings and
you see how reporters, some reporter, even
even not right wing reporters are adopting
the language that's been established by Republicans
about a crisis at the border, we looked at
the Border Patrol data seasonally.
This is when crossings go up.
You also have some kind of pent up demand
from 2020 where there was very little movement
because of the pandemic.
So it all seems in the range of what you would
expect seasonally.
Crisis to me is is the wrong word, but I think
they realize they're getting the most traction
with it.
And so that's why they're continuing to go
Kamala Harris now is being put in charge of
handling what's going on at the border.
What exactly what are the options even for
what Joe Biden could and should be doing there,
you know?
Despite his options, because it is a complicated
issue and it is a matter of capacity and the
speed with which they can actually move, particularly
children, through the system and make sure
the children are not there longer than they're
supposed to be there.
There is a very nuance and problematic issue
there at the border in terms of processing
and logistics.
There is no crisis, though, and I appreciate
you stating that because even you we saw MSNBC,
they're using this language.
Joe Scarborough has started using this language.
And it is a throwback to the Obama administration
when this is literally the number one way
they wanted to attack President Obama because
it does gain traction and it plays well with
the conservative base.
But that goes to the right wing, inherent
right wing framing that we get from mainstream
media anyway.
Right.
And the irony of it is, of course, these headlines
were not being promulgated during the Trump
administration.
Right.
When the numbers I'm sure if we look at the
numbers, there's going to be some overlap
in terms of comparability.
But now it is a talking point because this
is all they have.
This is what they're going to do.
And so we need to look at we need to question
these mainstream media outlets that are now
shifting to the same paradigm where they are
creating a crisis with their headlines versus
the reality of the data.
Yeah, to me, the crisis language that's being
used is not that different than China virus
and Sleepy Joe in the sense that the way you
describe it is what frames it.
Even for people who are questioning what Peter
Doocy says during, you know, the Jen Psaki
press briefings or whatever the case may be.
But for me, so far, if you say what's the
biggest mistake Joe Biden has made or the
biggest failure, it's that, yes, he did do
the executive order on removals and deportations.
And then the Texas judge said now the justification
is no good and Biden's not done anything since
when I read a lot of really good legal analyzes
that are Biden could redo those executive
orders to stop that with different legal justifications
and really put courts in a position to say
none of these justifications are valid.
He just did one executive order and has kind
of stepped away for now.
I don't like that.
That's for me one of the biggest things I
think he's done wrong.
Yeah, yeah.
I think that that would be one of the number
one things.
The number two thing is the willingness to
confront the issue head on for the difficulty
that it actually is.
I think Jen Psaki doesn't really do a really
good service to the administration by trying
to prevaricate around the complexity of the
situation versus simply saying that we don't
have the capacity that we need to actually
get these children out of these cages as soon
as we, you know, is just really direct language
is really necessary at this point, because
if if they're prevaricating too much, then
we're going to see these images.
And it's not just going to be the right is
going to be a lot of people on the left and
justifiably so, because if we see these images,
we may not know the the technical difference
between what's happening right now and what
happened during the Trump administration.
What we see are people in cages, and I think
they have to just do the very difficult job
of being straightforward and expanding the
capacity.
Don't just tell us the truth, help us change
the structural problems that are underneath
it.
One of the things I would like to see would
be to see Jen Psaki better prepared to lay
it out and say, listen, the system we were
handed was a disaster already.
We want to fix it.
But that will require, quote, growing government.
But the Republicans are also against that.
So the only way to do what they want us to
do is by expanding resources, hiring more
people, maybe in the short term, having more
facilities.
But they also say we need small government.
So how is it that they expect it to be fixed
if we can't do any of the things that need
to be done?
She doesn't.
She sometimes will say it's complex, but she'll
never really frame it in those terms.
Right.
So and then trust the American people to handle
the complexity right now.
I know that's asking a lot.
All things considered.
But have you seen the interviews with a..
People?
I know complexity is not playing well right
now.
Well, but complexity will will do well for
the people who are actually genuinely concerned
about.
Yeah, right.
You're going to have bad faith actors on both
sides of the equations that no matter what
this administration does, they're going to
get attacked for it.
That said, there are some of us who actually
are simply concerned about making sure that
not it's not even just about keeping promises,
but we're doing the absolute best that we
can for the human lives that come and seek
asylum in this country.
And so for those of us who are operating in
good faith, we can handle a moment of complexity
versus, you know, kind of dancing around the
issue.
Have you been surprised by how effective the
right wing media apparatus and Republicans
are at getting an idea to trickle all the
way down to what I would call random Republican
voters in diners in Oklahoma?
Like when CNN goes in and they do it, they
interview diners in Oklahoma or in Idaho or
whatever, and ideas that start with like Jim
Jordan and Lauren Bobert and Fox.
And friends about either a crisis at the border
or stuff about mandatory vaccine, whatever
it gets so quickly to just random Republican
voters in Oklahoma who just accept it.
Yeah, you know, it's it's a continuation of
the same echo chamber that they've mastered
over the last 40 years.
I mean, it used to start with Rush Limbaugh
and now, you know, it's being regurgitated
from through social media and on YouTube,
like YouTube does have the same talking points.
People on Twitter have the same talking points.
I mean, randoms like and here's the other
side of David.
You now actively have citizens through social
media contributing to and seeking out those
talking points so that they can have something
to say to their aunt that they don't like
who's a liberal on social media.
So they're they're indoctrinating and propagandizing
themselves.
What's funny about that is for the last at
least four years, but arguably longer, the
Republican Party has not been about policy,
but it's been about preventing the left from
doing anything and making the left look bad.
That's almost the ideology now of the random
Republican voter at Thanksgiving who is not
so much interested in policy, but in about
what can I say to embarrass my liberal cousin
or whatever the case may be?
Yeah, no, it's very personalized politics
at this point.
And it's the analogy of football teams couldn't
be any truer because they're special pleading
on behalf.
I mean, they don't care that it's illogical.
They don't care if it's downright a lie.
They just need something so that they can
post to on the libs that might be their questioners.
And then if it turns out that it's disinformation
not allowed on social media, the fact that
they're not allowed to post it becomes part
of the story that they tell.
Yeah, no, absolutely.
There's no greater grievance than a conservative
who has been flagged for propaganda that that
that will be interesting to follow.
Also, actually, during during the Biden administration.
I've got one last thing on this.
I've been thinking, OK, so they want to solve
council culture.
Is there any, quote, solution that is not
incredibly authoritarian government involvement
in private business?
I mean, there.
Oh, you mean for them to solve exactly when
they say we need to fix council culture on
social media, how do they imagine it being
done without regulating the hell out of these
platforms in a way that they claim to oppose?
You know, I think what they really want is
just to be able to use the N-word and not
get in trouble.
I think that I think that's their standard.
So if you allow that, they'll they'll forgive
the other stuff like that.
That's the end of cancer culture for this.
They want to be able to say anything they
want to say without any responsibility.
So, I mean, the amount of government that
would be required to come into, you know,
private corporations, private jobs and to
manage no responsibility for it's just a mess
thinking about it.
Yeah, they want freedom from the consequences
of speech, even if it's someone else's speech.
That is the consequence.
Absolutely.
We've been speaking with Ben Dixon, host of
The Benjamin Dixon Show.
You can find him on, of course, YouTube, occasionally
on Twitter.
Where else what's your like, main hub right
now, would you say?
I would say my main hub is the podcast format
is still one of the strongest sides.
So anywhere you get podcasts, I heart radio,
Spotify, all those places were there.
Ben, always great having you on.
Hey, thanks for having me, David.